foto bri hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge happy
uhr die letzten happy meals folge sind
schon zehn jahre her und ich dachte dass
das alte spiel das man nie wieder
rauskramen weil ich mega bock drauf habe
und ich würde sagen wir spielen
direktflügen löffeln jubelten bei der
die wir könnten ja mal
wir spielen jetzt ultimate payback
zusätzlich genau noch mal im level ja
wir sind schwarz mal auf dem rasen mähen
eigentlich guck mal da wissen wir später
prepare to interact okay wir müssen wir
loslassen
jetzt soll ich würde sagen gehen wir
hier in die obamas ihr ein anderer wie
gehen wir hier in die große welt wird
immer ein günstig die dänen nehmen wir
denn da wir nehmen wir nehmen wir
einfach mal angry stick das hat ja immer
noch im fokus stehen wir doch einfach
mal den ist das hier der fokus weg sind
das ist der focus de kommt also bitte
[Musik]
okay leute kommen denn wir schaffen das
dem ziel schneller
[Musik]
okay das ist level ist es scheiße neon
tokyo adventure player gibt es ja auch
davids die länger dauern als ewig und
der bi justin bieber okay wir sind schon
mal auf dem luk seite geklärt sind wir
weit kommen sollte das kann man
natürlich sind natürlich heute somit
sehen wie beschreibt man allem vor dem
sprung in die kommentare ob ich ein semi
problem derzeit für ja oder nein ja oder
ja oder nein ja oder nein ja oder ja
oder nein ihr habt abgeschickt okay wenn
sie migros der client wii sports
doch krank alter kommt jakob wie wege
weg graben und sie einfach so kommen wir
sind wir sind die schnecke winston nein
uns du schaffst das lustvolle den
künsten raus jetzt los du schaffst es ja
wissen ja da kommt der winston ja/nein
32 austria extreme sind extreme masters
münster schickt das system walter einen
winston die schnecke die stärke winston
denkt gar nicht schmecken
okay ein haben wir eine alternative sind
wieder runter okay okay okay wir sind ok
das resultat des sprungs wir sind sogar
noch ein zurückgekommen wünschen
los ging's nicht loben dich hier drin
ich hoffe mal die schnecke packt er's
waren ja nur sechs minuten
gt5 okay leute gta 5 soll somit das
beste level das ich je gespielt habe das
bekommt von mir unglaubliche fünf sterne
wir haben eine seite jungs okay okay wir
fahren weiter das licht werden noch eine
seite
bei uns läuft auf jeden fall ich habe
ihnen die angst ist er trotzdem jetzt
werden die kommt war steht dabei stand
david haye dass mein herz du selbst du
schaffst das ja das machen wir nochmal
so jetzt machen kann man schnell
durchlauf ok resultat bisher wir haben
ein bein verloren aber das ist unnötig
das rechte bein das braucht keiner da
ist nix hey hey what's the world peace
of paper fallout 3
das könnte jetzt mir wir müssen uns
jetzt nicht bei allen das noch ein blatt
westlotto nation playnow dass mein herz
muss man kind
das heißt wenn mein kind mein herz mein
herz ist heute ist heute ist heute ist
sich hochrein es wieder runter gedrückt
[Musik]
so dass ich angst davor hätten
un-vertreter catch as catch up workshop
[Musik]
wird das geht lesen justin bieber smash
alter toll jetzt habe ich hier aus
ich will feierabend okay leute wir
schaffen das schaffen dass elf mir raus
er will nur noch raus und feierabend
haben leute das war's mit der heutigen
folge happy meals ich habe mal wieder so
ein bisschen was zusammengeschnitten ich
hab ich ja mal gefragt ob wir es haben
wollte dann hätte wird zum beispiel das
war er bei spielen wollt ihr mehr dass
ich so etwas mache auch eventuelle
zweifel ganz einfach die besten zehn
rausgeschnitten wir auf den fachmann
wenn ihr den daumen hoch gehen würde
schafft die community 5550 damen holten
wir auf jeden fall haben wir gleich
schreibt in die kommentare wird das
video gebannt auf dem er davon haben
wollte dann will ich sagen ich möchte
wieder so schnell das ganze muss ich dir
sind beim nächster wieder zu
[Musik]